The final days before the Iowa caucuses
as the Republican front
runner is packing up his personal 757
and leaving the state
because Donald Trump
opting for sitting in court
rather than going to speak
to voters and campaign
in front of them tomorrow,
that is something he is choosing to do.
Option.
We will speak about that,
the lawyer later in the hour.
But that comes as his two leading
challengers are begging for
votes, is also battling each other.
Also, meanwhile,
President Biden
today was in South Carolina,
making it clear
who he expects
to be facing
as the Republican nominee come November.
We saw something on January six
we had never seen before,
even during the Civil War.
Insurrectionists waving Confederate flags
inside the halls of Congress
built by enslaved Americans.
For hours,
the defeated former president
sat in a private dining room
off of my half of the Oval Office
and did nothing. Nothing.
Absolutely nothing.
Losers are taught to concede
when they lose.
He's a loser.
No holding back there in that speech.
I'm joined tonight by former
Republican Congressman
Adam Kinzinger and former Obama
administration official Van Jones.
Thank you both for being here tonight.
And, Van,
you know,
there was this one line
from President Biden.
You know, he's in South Carolina.
He's attempting to rally black voters
and he's been losing support
with them in the state that helped really
propel him
to the nomination back in 2020.
But he drew this direct line at one point
during the speech.
And I want everyone to listen to this.
Between this history of white supremacy
to what the former president
is doing today,
in our time,
there's still the old ghost
of new government, a new government.
We all need to rise to meet the moment,
the moment is now.
I mean, Ben,
what did you make of him
essentially arguing that, you know, this
those who say the Confederate rebellion
was this noble cause,
that it was self-serving,
as Biden was putting it in the same way
that he says Trump is rewriting history
by trying to falsely claim
that the election was stolen?
Yeah, you know,
I thought it was
actually pretty powerful.
It wasn't a frame
I thought of before I heard before,
you know, the lost cause,
You know, that's sort of the
I grew up in Tennessee.
You know, some of us are Southerners and,
you know, that kind of,
you know, we we have this lost cause.
And you look back
and you go back
over and over and over again,
and this is like a second lost
cause is like what Biden is saying,
that the Southern Confederates
were defeated
and they would never admit it.
And now you've got the Trump
machine defeated and it won't admit it.
And he's drawing a line
between that refusal
to deal with reality
and the violence of of, you know, January
the seventh and January six
and the potential violence
that could come with this election.
So for me, I think he's doing a good job
trying to get back to his home turf,
South Carolina,
get back to the black base,
reminding them of some of the stuff
that maybe people have forgotten about
and reframing
what we're seeing
as a part
of a long tradition
of very,
very dangerous politics in America.
And Congressman Kinzinger,
I mean, this comes as Elise
Stefanik yesterday on the Sunday shows.
She is the Republican conference chair,
and she's now echoing the language
that the former president is using
when it comes
to the January six defendants,
the people who went to the Capitol
and rioted that day,
describing them as hostages.
This is what she said on Meet the Press.
I have
concerns about the
treatment of January six hostages.
I have concerns.
We have a role in Congress of oversight
over our treatment of prisoners.
And I believe that
we're seeing the weaponization
of the federal government
against not just President Trump,
but we're seeing it
against conservatives.
What did you make,
Congressman, of seeing
such a prominent member of your party
saying that?
Well, I mean, Elise is so incredibly,
insanely thirsty to be vice president.
I mean, that's what she's doing.
She's out there
mimicking what Donald Trump says.
He knows he's watching
and he probably center attacks,
told her good job, Elise.
And she felt really good about herself.
I mean, that's what she's doing
and she's doing it.
And this is a look,
if I'm a rank and file
member of the House still, here's
where I would be upset,
because I used to be able to just say,
oh, Donald Trump,
you know, I don't know what he says.
I'm not paying attention.
You now have the leader of the
messaging branch,
what you say as a Republican.
The conference chair comes up
talking points
now saying there, January six hostages.
Here's what you're going to see.
Caitlin,
this is now going to be echoed over
and over
as it becomes a litmus test,
whether you're a true
conservative or not,
whether you say hostages or prisoners,
and soon you're going to see more
and more people saying this.
I think it's so obvious.
It's just one of the areas,
I think,
as well as Joe Biden did in that speech,
one of the areas
I think he really needs to push
even harder on
is there's this idea
that Donald Trump is a tough person
who's doing this authoritarian things
because he's strong.
The reality is he's a he's he's a whiner.
He's frightened, He's scared.
He's doing this
because he's a victim in his own mind
and he wants to convince
everybody he's a victim.
Donald Trump
is actually a very weak person.
And I think that's
the way to do real damage in this base,
even though it's not necessarily
going to turn the primary
or anything like that around.
A lot of questions about what
that primary will look like.
Van Jones, Adam Kinzinger,
as always, thank you both.